yeah welcome to this video playing white
against qe1 decay that sections posters
sicilian for the open one then I denied
or hmm ok let's go for this English tick
hmm and I thought g5 now I thought g4
would prevent default this isn't this
the case what is he doing now really i
don't i don't really know the theory
here i can recapture of course he can
recapture
hmm well this doesn't look too too great
yeah what the heck was went wrong there
isn't she for Norma move I'm really a
bit shocked here or do I need to take on
d4 now in this position I don't know
okay but let's try to still on Phi TM
looks a really strange yeah i mean the
fork before so i get he will get one
piece back and of course my king site
resembles the the proverbial swiss
cheese kingi to this Bishop to c4 need
to do that Jack Jack yeah wow this is
really crap oh my
Jack yeah Bishop g2 is got Bishop 283
this doesn't help and queen III even
that's also crap Kim oh yeah what a
disaster yeah yeah I completely forgot
that he can take on f6 yeah yeah yeah
don't tell me you want to draw your
family doesn't okay I don't know should
I take only six yeah probably i should
then cleaned e621 trifle for some play
on only six here also I want to prevent
castles rukon f8 so rather rather
problem came here maybe this isn't so
terrible I don't add this I don't see a
director a direct way for him to call me
sd-6 is saying oh this is nice so it's
good for me good and game
okay it is a good endgame the homeless
the night doesn't have any big bigger
squares and this isn't isn't so much
this isn't a big deal the zoo care for
and stuff I actually can weaken the
structure here when I should have played
c3 yeah okay come on it's not if he
takes on e2 it's not the end of the
world admittedly but I should have
played c3 anyway
hmm now is probably active enough to
draw this oh but now what what about you
five yeah but the Sun didn't help you
from the he am intending to take a
droopier to g5 winning the spawn it's
not clear what is move us now yeah just
the bed structure I've got three against
two on the on the queenside yeah just
here IM cesium yeah but this is a really
good endgame
look to d7 own
roop d7 our route d6 that some rope
teasing i can play king of things
okay let's get this moving
Jim is actually helping me to to to get
a pest porn with the rope behind it so
so quite uncommon
yeah well still king of to us was
nonsense I need to get the King on the
queenside of course and to be five
yeah a few the king and the sea porn
should should win should win on their
own yeah yeah what a weird game I have
completely completely butchered the
opening what the heck is going on down
isn't this low move or you do you play
Queen D to get this is really really
something but ok it said I don't really
really don't know the theory but this is
certainly completely completely crazy
for me I'm a terrible terrible shape
yeah yeah yeah check check check someone
has it worked out here this was what was
really bad I mean after this I'm I'm
certainly good maybe
I mean if you don't have anything great
then you can still play Queen h4 in 27
getting a better version of this end
game but Queen f6 is also long possible
maybe this is better yeah yeah like here
now yeah i mean my kingdom cannot be
cannot be a great really I was glad that
I still had some sort of position but I
can play and maybe just take with this
idea yeah I don't know something like
that you have group th look the hd2 yeah
it's just crap for white what can you do
this is this is wrong with longer looks
very normal but maybe they play Queen d2
yeah this really irritates me or just
right just take now this is probably
nonsense or you take on d4 this this
could be it could be one idea this
sounds maybe just yeah but that's I
don't get dg7 yeah I just played played
this badly this it most lucky at the end
you get this good endgame thanks for
watching